and all the time
yes indeed he is thank you very much
sister for your
song i appreciate it i really do
and may god bless you as you sing for
his glory
i'm glad god brought us safely it is a
little wet outside the roads tend to get
slippery but we're grateful for safety
safety is never guaranteed so whenever
the child of god arrives at his or her
destination safely
we should
instinctively
thank god for traveling mercies i mean
instinctively and that of course only
comes by training the mind
to thank god
for everything
and i was talking to uh elder gilbert
today
and i was telling him i'm trying to
discipline myself
whenever i see something
let's say i see someone
with a finger missing
then i thank god for 10
and commit that turn to the gospel
i fly a lot and sometimes people come on
the planes on wheelchairs
and i say father
i hope my preaching can accelerate the
coming of christ so all of this will
come to an end
and i commit my physical fitness to the
gospel
if i see someone with a cane
lord i thank pr be merciful to that man
or woman but please accept my sight
as an offering in the gospel so i'm
saying to you
let us try in everything
to see god's goodness
and to regularly commit ourselves and
all that we have
to him
so i say again god is good
and all the time
god is good i am genuinely delighted to
see you and i thank you for coming my
dear sister doctor
where's the doctor
when you said you don't like cats we
cease to be friends
i just love cats
maybe i won't make it to the kingdom i
don't know maybe i have a small frontal
lobe the size of split pea but i just
love cats
oh when i was a little boy we had a lot
of cats and there's nothing more
luxurious than to have a cat sleep in
the small of your back oh
i miss my not a dog too heavy a cat or
sleep on your stomach i love cats anyway
but if that's a sin then i repent to the
doctor
for loving cat our subject for this
evening from adam to adam
from adam
to adam
it's a seven after eight r7
the first fifa i usually request of you
is that you turn your phones off
and i will turn mine off right now it's
gone
dead
the second favorite i politely request
is that you pray for me while i'm
speaking and simply say
lord put your words in that man's mouth
that
is an urgent request from me
and favor number three please think as
you listen think
let me point here think
as you listen let's pray
our loving father in heaven
we thank you today god for bringing us
to this holy place
safely
without any mishap
we thank you the father for the
privilege of worship
and we thank you for the ministry of the
spirit that makes the world clear to us
father as i deliver this message speak
through me to god i offer myself to you
as an unresisting uncomplaining tool use
me as you see fit
let the spirit possessing and speaking
through me be the spirit that enlightens
those who listen
i ask you to pronounce a special
blessing day god on those who are
visiting with us for the first time at
the end of this service let us know that
it was good to have been here i offer
this prayer in jesus name let god's
people say amen and amen from adam to
adam
let us go to romans chapter 5.
romans 5 we shall read verse 12.
romans 5 verse 12.
the bible says for as by one man
sin entered into the world and death by
sin and so death passed upon all men for
that all have sinned let's look at the
first part of that verse again for as by
one man
sin entered into the world
not by one woman when eve sinned her sin
affected her alone
when adam sinned it affected the entire
creation
are you with me
let me say it again
when eve sinned her sin affected her
very narrow area of effect when adam
sinned his sin affected the entire uh
creation and so god said to him in
genesis 3 17
because thou has hearkened unto the
voice of thy wife and has eaten of the
tree of which i commanded thee saying
thou shalt not eat of it curse is the
ground for thy sake what part of the
ground did god mean
just the ground in the garden
what ground did god mean the earth the
entire earth was cursed in verse 18
thorns also thistles shall it bring
forth unto thee and thou shalt eat the
herb of the field in the sweat of thy
face verse 19 shalt thou eat bread so
there's a curse on the earth and there's
a curse regarding people having to work
for their living the ground will be
difficult to till just a curse
creation wide because of one man
now let's go to romans 5 verse 18.
romans 5 verse 18
therefore as by the offense of one
judgment came upon all men the
condemnation
even so by the righteousness of one the
free gift came upon all the
justification of life now
we have adam referred to again but now
we have another person introduced
are you with me
let's read that first slowly if you have
it read with me are you ready romans 5
18 if you have my version what does it
say
therefore as by the offense of one stop
what do you understand by offense give
me another word for offense
sin very good therefore as by the
offense of one
who is that
but how many people sinned in the garden
two but which one was responsible for
the sin affecting the whole world one
man give me that man's name adam
therefore as by the offense of one
judgment came upon all men to
condemnation
even so
by the righteousness of one the free
gift came upon all to justification of
life now
we have offense
what's the opposite of offense in that
verse don't answer me quickly think what
is the opposite of offense or right or
sin in that verse
in the verse
righteousness related my brother you're
correct uh my good brother in the
expensive looking picture you also
correct don't worry
are you correct i just wanted the word
the precise word righteousness listen
again therefore as by the offense of one
even so by the righteousness of one and
so the opposite of sin is
righteousness
by one man's sin the whole world is
affected by one man's obedience a
blessing came upon the whole world look
at verse 19
for as by one man's word
disobedience many were made sinners go
on so by the obedience of one shall many
be made righteous now 18 and 19 are
saying the same thing
now what two words correspond to each
other in 18 and 19. let me see who is
really smart with a large frontal lobe
let me see who it is yes my brother
offense and disobedience that's right
now give me the opposite side the
opposite pair
righteousness
and obedience
listen to me
righteousness
is obedience
sin
is disobedience
but what i wanted you to see that the
two verses have these two men
therefore as by the offense of one
judgment came upon all mental
condemnation even so by the
righteousness of one the free gift came
upon all men to justification of life
verse 19 fires by one man disobedience
many were made sinners so by the
obedience of one shall maybe be made
righteous we have this man doing
something having a large effect that man
doing something having a large effect
let's go to first corinthians 15.
first corinthians 15
we shall read
verse 21 and verse 22 our subject is
from adam to adam
first corinthians 15 reading verse 21
the bible says for since my man came
what
by man came also what the resurrection
of the dead here again we have these two
men
one brought what
the other brought life
verse 22 what does that verse say for as
in adam all die
so in christ shall all be made alive we
have these two men again what i want you
to see is that there is a relationship
a parallel
relationship not necessarily of the same
nature but a parallel relationship
between adam and christ
we are all born of which adam
the first one consequently we're born
with what disposition what mind
a sinful mind in which direction is our
frontal lobe lean
sin
now
we have to move from that atom
to the next
because in him where does the frontal
lobe lane
righteousness
or life
or obedience
so we go from one adam
from adam
to adam everyone comes into the world in
the first adam or a product of
now jesus told the nicodemus you must be
what born again you've got to come back
you came through the wrong atom
you had no choice
now you have a choice to come back
through the second adam
who is the adam of life
the adam of obedience the adam of
righteousness in him
we are obedient
we have life
and we have righteousness
let us go to verse 45 of first
corinthians 15
our subject from adam
to adam
before we go to we read verse 45 we'll
also read verse 47.
i just said in the first adam we have
death in the second adam we have life
now in the first adam the death we have
is our death
because romans 5 12 said all have sinned
the death is hours by right
in the second adam the life is not ours
are you following me
okay thank you sister for saying no
in the first adam what's the punishment
for sin
death how many of us have sinned
so what do we deserve
death clear
we come to the first adam that's what we
deserve death
jesus christ came and committed how many
sins
none and so he overcame where the first
adam
fell
because of the first adam's fall we
inherit what death because of the
victory of the second adam we have
access to what life
but the life is not ours naturally
are you with me
the life is whose christ and that life
is given to us unconditionally
that we do what
is that we do what
repent and give the life to christ so
when we're in christ his life becomes
ours but death is ours naturally
we are the children of wrath outside of
christ what i'm saying is here's the
first adam here's the second adam he
sinned death he was victorious life
let's look at verse 45
and so it is written the first man adam
was made a living soul the last adam was
made what
a quickening spirit now just look at the
two atoms
let's look at them again the two atoms
the first man adam was made what a
living soul the bible says and the lord
god formed adam from the dust of the
earth and dust of the ground and
breathed into his nostrils the breath of
life and man became a living soul now a
living soul what the verse is implying
the first adam was given life by
somebody
are you with me
if you're not do like my sister didn't
say no let me say it again
did adam give himself life yes or no
who gave him life
listen to the verse and so it is written
the first man adam was made a living
soul
someone gave him life
the one the second adam or the last adam
was made what
a quick what is a quickening spirit
what does it mean to quicken
to give life
the first adam someone gave him life
the second adam he gives life
ah you didn't get it this is absolutely
critical when jesus stood at the grave
of lazarus and martha doubted that
lazarus he said i know he will rise
again in the resurrection of the last
day jesus said what i am what the
resurrection come on what did he say and
the life he sent that while he was human
because he was also
god
the second adam had power to give life
are you with me
life is natural inherent to jesus christ
as an author said in him is life
original underrived and borrowed no one
gives christ life he is life
this is the record that god hath given
to us eternal life first john 5 11 and
this life is in his son which means to
have the life that god offers we must
have jesus
uh mr cameraman mr camera lady i'm about
to move a little bit so
keep me focused here's what i mean
here's what some people think coming to
christ is
here's christ
and they want life
they think they go to christ
say may i have life
christ puts life in their hand they say
thank you and then they walk away
that's not the way it works
we go to christ we say i want life
christ says i am life
if you want me if you want life what you
have to do
you have to take me so if we want life
we go to christ we take christ
and we don't go back we stay right there
amen
you don't go to christ get life say
thank you profoundly and then walk away
no no no the life is christ himself
you're looking at me very nicely but
you're not getting it
well i can't think of a simple way to
put it
jesus himself
is life
the first adam
is dirt
that's what god said
actually it was jesus who said that thus
thou art and he said that while adam was
alive
genesis 3 19 he says thus thou art
abraham said behold now i have taken
upon me to speak unto him which i'm but
dustin ashes abraham said i am only dust
psalm 103 verse 14 he knoweth our frame
he remembereth that we are dust
even when we are living we are dirt
we are dust
jesus is life can you say amen and so to
have the life of christ you must have
christ
but you can't have the second adam of
the first
you've got to get rid of one
and you get rid of that one
through conversion
and the steps that follow conversion let
me say it again
you cannot live in both atoms
the first atom passed on what
death
the second atom allows us to inherit or
to receive life
by receiving him
let's look at verse
47.
the first man
or the first yes man is of the earth
earthy the second man is the lord from
heaven and so again we have these two
men
but the first one is just earthy
the second one is god
salvation requires
we move
from one adam to the next
now
both men stand at the head of the human
race
the first atom represented the race the
second atom also represents the race
let me say that again
the first adam
is a representative of the race
but the race
in sin
unable to help itself
the second atom represents the race
under probation which is life and with
the possibility of change by
surrendering to christ
the failure of the first adam is what
we're born with
the victory of the second is available
to the whole human race when jesus said
in response to satan in matthew 3 verse
4 it is written man shall not live by
bread alone jesus referred to the entire
race of which he was the head and he was
apart
and so what jesus accomplished he
accomplished as the head of the race
representing us meaning that that
accomplishment then becomes ours on
conditions that we do what give our
lives to jesus christ let me say that
again the victory of christ in the
wilderness is ours if we accept christ
by faith
every victory christ won is available to
us if we accept jesus christ now
with having said that
let's go to matthew
chapter
3.
we go before we go to matthew 3 let's go
to acts 2.
so many things christ has done for us of
which we're not aware
and because we're not aware we don't tap
into that power
and we're christians who live weak lives
and so we misrepresent god
because if there's no victory then why
should someone want to become one of us
acts 2
verse 37
peter has paused in his pentecost sermon
the bible says now when they heard this
they were print in their heart and said
unto peter unto the rest of the apostles
men and brethren
what
shall we do
then peter said unto them what
repent go on be baptized
now
baptism
must be preceded by what repentance
that's why you cannot baptize a baby
now you can christen a baby i was
christian i was a catholic
i was a good catholic i wanted to be a
priest
then my mother found out that the local
priest had his eyes on me for the
priesthood
and according to my sister's account of
the story my mother kept me home she did
not want me to be a priest
so i decided to be a seventh-day
adventist pastor and preacher instead
now
baptism must be preceded by repentance
and so i repeat a baby cannot repent a
baby cannot be baptized
let us go to acts 3 verse 19 the same
man is preaching saint peter as the
catholics call him
we have acts 3 19 peter says repenty
therefore be converted
that your sins may be blotted out when
the times of refreshing shall come from
the presence of the lord here again we
have repentance
conversion which involves baptism
because when you come out of the water
it symbolizes a new life that's
conversion so repent and be converted
repent and be baptized are perfectly in
harmony
let's go to matthew chapter 3 we shall
read verse 8 listen to the words of john
the baptist
when the pharisees and the sadducees
came to him you know he said in verse 7
or generation of vipers who have warned
you to flee from the wrath to come bring
forth therefore fruits need for what
repentance before i baptize you
repent
i'm baptized in the river jordan so we
have repent repent repent this is a
message to man sinners repent
then baptism repent then baptism now
let me challenge your minds and they're
all sharp
now let's go to matthew 3.
from adam to adam
matthew chapter 3 reading from verse 13
then cometh jesus from galilee to jordan
unto john to be baptized of him
but john forbid him saying i have need
to be baptized of thee and cometh down
to me and jesus answering said unto him
suffer it to be so now for thus it
becometh us
to fulfill what
all
righteousness
jesus is telling john i must take this
step
now
what is the implication then
the bible is already laid out what must
precede baptism
don't say so hesitatingly speak with
confidence even when you're wrong are
you with me now what precedes baptism
repentance now here comes jesus
i need to be baptized
john says no jesus says i need to
fulfill
not just this act of righteousness but
all righteousness
which means
that christ had already done
something
what was that
he repented
now before you call the conference
president and say i'm preaching error
let me take my time are you with me
did christ commit any sins yes or no
so if he repented of who sins that he
repent ours
the same way he was baptized for us
he had to have repented for us
and confessed for us
he died for us
because he committed no sin are you with
me
you can't stop the for us for us for us
when you get to repentance
you cannot say he was baptized for us he
died for us he resisted sin for us but
he didn't repent for us
listen to me
that's the
everything you do
must be done on the basis of what christ
has already done
so when you say father i repent of my
sin i i cheated on that exam
you know how your repentance is accepted
by god
on the strength of the repentance of
jesus christ for you 2 000 years ago
now you have to say i'm sorry yes
but the acceptability of your repentance
is based on the fact that it rests on
the perfect repentance of jesus because
no sinner can perfectly repent
when i confess my confession is accepted
by god because jesus christ has
previously offered a perfect confession
and it is upon that that god accepts my
faulty uh confession or should i say god
accept my confession as is presented in
the confession of christ
not my faulty one
it is carried god on the strength of
christ's confession
so when jesus got baptized now
he got baptized for whom
us
so that when you were baptized tomorrow
your baptism is acceptable to god on the
strength of the perfect baptism of jesus
christ are you with me his baptism
becomes yours as you participate in that
physical act by faith in him when you
repent your repentance is accepted
because you believe that jesus has
already offered a perfect repentance
which is the platter on which you offer
yours
there is nothing you can bring to god
that's acceptable to god outside of
jesus christ nothing
and so jesus
went down into the water
bible says let's read from verse
and he suffered him verse 16 and jesus
of matthew 3 when he was baptized went
up straight away out of the water and
lord the heavens were opened unto him
and he saw the spirit of god descending
like a dove unlighting upon him a law a
voice from heaven saying what this is my
beloved son in whom i am well pleased
now let's see if you're thinking
to whom did the god the father say that
yes
let me give you a second chance to
redeem yourselves to whom did god the
father say that based on all that i've
said to whom did god the father speak
to those of us who accept that baptism
by faith by ourselves going down he says
to us you are my beloved son in whom i
am well pleased and you who are baptized
tomorrow you must hear that sound
in the baptism of jesus you are
the one to whom god says this is my
beloved son this is my beloved daughter
because when jesus was baptized he was
baptized as the representative of a race
that's why there's nothing god can do
for you outside of jesus do you
understand me
the very life
you take the most violent criminal in
south africa whoever he or she may be
that person is alive right now within a
jail cell or hiding somewhere in the
movie
because of christ
now christ isn't keeping that person
alive to keep sinning
to give the person a chance to repent
let me say it again
every person who lives
is alive because of christ
the moon
goes around the earth
the earth goes around the sun the stars
maintain their courses because of christ
when you drink water
the atomic balance you know two hydrogen
one of oxygen is arranged and preserved
by christ
because if you add one more molecule of
a
atom of a of oxygen you have hydrogen
peroxide
all
christ
and so when we're baptized tomorrow
we must be conscious
christ offered to the father a perfect
baptism
through that my baptism is accepted to
god and god will say this is my beloved
son as ex as as excitedly as he said
about jesus christ
i confuse you just now let me say it
again
when god says to you tomorrow those of
you who baptized who understand your
baptism is accepted through the baptism
of christ when you hear god say by faith
this is my beloved son or my beloved
daughter he will say it with as much
excitement for you
as he said it
for jesus
this is one of the bible truths that
blows the mind or that blow the mind
truths that blow the mind
go to john 17.
our subject is
from adam to adam
you can't live in both at the same time
you were born in one but you must be
reborn in the other john 17 verse 23
ladies do you have that
ladies you have my version
you don't have it
who has the king james version raise it
up let me see or raise your hand or
something all right read ladies what is
john 17 23 saying
i am them and thou in me that they what
perfect in one and that the world may
that thou has sent me finished the last
part loudly and has loved them how as
thou has loved me this is this is
concussive
how can god
love me
as much as he loves jesus
when i
am in christ
do you know god
loves some people more than others
okay let me use different wording
do you know god is closer to some people
than he is to others by choice
let me give you a fascinating quotation
desire of ages page 524 paragraph one
write it down you're looking at me write
it down
the desire of ages page 5 24 paragraph 1
listen to these words
are you finished writing the reference
the savior bless all who sought his help
he loves all the human family
but to some
he is bound by peculiarly tender
associations his heart was nicked by a
strong bond of affection to the family
at bethany and for one of them his most
wonderful work was right
jesus reserved his greatest miracle for
the family closest to him
you know why he loved him so much
remember the story of mary and martha
whenever he came to their home
they loved to receive his word they
loved to receive him
and christ would go there often imagine
god himself enjoying human companionship
he longed for it in his humanity he
longed for genuine friendship
and he decided consciously i will honor
this family with my greatest miracle but
listen to the bible let's go to john 14
as we continue from adam to adam
and i'm telling you that when god says
tomorrow this is my beloved son or
daughter in whom i am well pleased he
will say with as much earnestness for
you as he said it for christ john 17
reading from verse 21
john 14. god bless you john 14.
thank you very much that's how you
should tell me to slow down quickly john
14 reading from verse 21 the bible says
he that hath my commandments and keepeth
them here is that love with me let me
just pause and digress it was not
digression
most people hath the commandments
read the first part of the verse again
he that
come on read loudly he that hath my
commandments and keepeth them stop most
people fulfill the first part of that
they have the commandments in the bible
on the shelf
keeping them is another story
god is specific you've got to have them
and keep them now here's the outcome
heed at half my commandments and keepeth
them here it is
in other words of the large multitude
that always say i love jesus
everybody loves jesus
i've never met a man who hated jesus
in the places i preached never met a
woman how many love jesus everybody's
hand goes up jesus says he that hath my
commandments and keepeth them here is
that love with me and he that loveth me
what's the next word shall now what
tense is shall
fusion
listen to the words
shall be loved of my father
and i
will love him
and will manifest myself now
the bible says god loves the whole world
right or wrong
yes
but when someone obeys god
that person enters into a deeper love of
god
than the disobedient.
the devil knows that obedience is the
basis of a deeper more intense love
relationship with god and so he gets us
to disobey
read the verse again he that hath my
commandments and keepeth them here is
that love with me and he that loveth me
shall be loved of my father a deeper
love than the general of express in john
3 16 and i will love him a deeper love
from christ and will manifest myself to
him
now
does god try to manifest himself to
everyone yes
but there is a special more tailored
manifestation for those who do what give
me one word obey
judah saith unto him not iscariot verse
22 lord how is it that thou will
manifest thyself unto us and not into
the world what does jesus say in verse
23 he that what
he that loves me will
keep my command
and go on read and my father will
and we will come unto him and
make our bold with him
what's the condition for god living in
your house in the house of your heart
obedience
now
i said all of that to emphasize what i
said earlier
when god says tomorrow to you and you
hear it by faith this is my beloved son
when you come out of that water
because you must complete the process
you can't step into the pool and then
say it's too cold walk out you won't
hear this is my beloved son are you with
me you've got to step in go down and
come up
so christ heard it when he completed the
physical symbol of baptism when you hear
that with the ear of faith this is my
beloved son or daughter
understand that the father is saying it
with as much excitement over you
as he said it over jesus
from adam to adam
if you are still in the first adam get
out
that's a house on fire
and that fire is called hell
get into the second adam
by surrendering your life to christ
that his life
may be your life
his repentance may be your repentance
his confession may be your confession
his victory over sin may be our victory
of a sin and tomorrow his baptism may be
your baptism
get out of the first atom
move into the second
and that's described in many ways in the
bible let's go to matthew 12 and then
i'll end
we have a long day tomorrow
i'll make a call at the end of this
message there's some people who still
need to decide to be baptized and i'll
give you that chance to let god know
that your heart is in the right
direction
matthew 12 we'll see the two adams again
reading from verse 22 our subject from
adam to adam
the bible says then was brought unto him
one possessed with the devil blind and
dumb and he healed him in so much that
the blind and dumb both spake and saw
let me digress again and pick on that
word in so much
you know we think god is a god who does
minor miracles
listen again listen read the word
microscopically
then was brought unto him one possessed
with a devil
that's the most powerful force in the
universe under god the power of satan
let me say it differently
only god is more powerful than satan
this man was controlled by the second
greatest power the power of satan
now then was brought unto him one
possessed not just troubled possessed
with the devil this led to blindness and
dumbness the bible says and he did what
healed him but to what extent
in so much
to such an extent
that the man's condition was absolutely
reversed
so that the blind and dumb finish the
verse
that is what jesus wants to do in your
life
reverse your condition
too often we go to god for a little
band-aid what do you call it in south
africa abandoned what do you call it
plaster bell you know you got a cut you
put something on that's what we go to
god for and god says i have power to
reverse
the cancer of your sin
and so i say again
then was brought unto him one possessed
with the devil blind and dumb to be
possessed with the devil you must be
living in which adam
the first
when god delivered that man he moved
into the second adam
that's why jesus said in verse 29 or
else how can one enter into a strong
man's house and spoil his goods except
he first bind the strong man and then he
will spoil his house the strong man is
satan the one who breaks in his christ
the goods are people
you go from the house of satan
being born in adam
to the house of christ
being born again of the second adam
and so my brothers and sisters
when you tear you're the first adam
when you wheat where are you
when you're goat where are you
come on speak when your goat where are
you
when you're sheep where are you
yes
tonight
christ is itching
the father is dying for some people to
make a move
from one adam finish it for me to the
next
now
that man who was demon-possessed he
moved from one atom to the next or from
one kingdom to the next
when the pharisees heard it they said
this fellow doth not cast out devils but
by belgium of the prince of devils verse
24 and jesus knew their thoughts and
said unto them every kingdom divided
itself every king is blocked is brought
to desolation every city a house divided
against himself shall not stand if satan
cast out satan he is divided against
himself how shall then his kingdom stand
verse 28
but if i cast out devils by the spirit
of god then the kingdom of god is come
unto you now we have two kingdoms two
adams really
that man in his possessed condition was
in the kingdom of satan
christ by his grace transformed him to
the kingdom of god
from one adam
to the in that instant the transfer was
made
when that publican said lord be merciful
to me the sinner he went from the
kingdom of satan to the kingdom of grace
from adam one to adam two
tonight if you believe you're living in
adam one you can walk out of this place
connected to adam two
it is only in the second atom that
there's life
and that life is the adam himself jesus
christ
and so i thank god very much
for the second adam who came
to redeem the errors the weakness the
fall the tragedy of the first
and the the parallel is so close
the first one fell on appetite the
second one overcame
on the same point
appetite
and so tonight
the power of the second adam is
available to you
and to me
the victory of the second adam is
available to us if we will simply by
faith without understanding all the
details of that divine operation just
say lord i surrender my life to you
i accept
the sacrifice the victory and the life
of the second adam
i want to live my life
in him
day
by day
how many of you say father
thank you for the second adam and i
recommit my life to him may i see your
hand i recommit my life i want you to
mean it don't just raise your hands
because you think you'll make me feel
good
preachers get to the place where they're
not embarrassed when no hands are raised
put your hands down for a minute
do not raise your hand to please me
i speak with respect
you know it becomes a habit to raise
your hand in a church
think of what you're doing
front to lobe activity
if you will say in the presence of a
holy god who records everything we do
father i recommit my life to this second
adam you raise your hand
you stand
my second appeal is simple
is there a man or a woman boy or girl
who has not yet made a decision to be
baptized
to enter into the baptism of the second
adam you want to say tonight father i am
making the decision tonight
if there's such a person can you raise
your right hand you have not yet made
that god bless you to be baptized you'll
make it tonight pastor
we have a son of god right here
even ah ah god bless you we have a
daughter of god to my left
please get the information name and
contact this is a serious decision
tonight you'll say i am making the
decision tonight i want to live my life
under the protection of the life of the
second adam so that his victory is mine
as i remain in him
his baptism will be mine as i
participate in it
when i repent it will be accepted on the
strength of his when i confess it's
accepted on the strength of his
anyone else
i am deciding tonight
i want to be baptized or re-baptized
live in the second adam over to my left
pastor oh we have another hand over here
or maybe that's the same hand i'm not
sure
okay
right in the second row we have two
hands god bless you my two sisters
anyone else 60 seconds and i pray let me
go a little higher so i can look over
the congregation
any other hands
father i am deciding tonight
to enter into the baptism of the second
adam
only in him
is there life
and the hope
of entering god's kingdom only in him
outside of christ there is no life
30 seconds
and if you're already baptized walking
with god you've renewed that commitment
it should be renewed every day when you
wake up renew it first thing in the
morning should be renewing the
commitment to god
and living with the consciousness that
christ won the victory for me when i try
i try in his strength
heads bowed eyes closed
our father in heaven
we thank you for
the second adam
we're sorry for the cast catastrophe of
the first
but you in your wisdom your mercy your
immeasurable love dear god you
understand devise a plan
whereby the second member of the godhead
would assume human form pass through the
experience of the first adam and
overcome produce a radically different
result
and we through faith in him participate
in his victory
over sin
over temptation
we participate in his repentance in his
confession
in his baptism
and ultimately we will participate in
his marvelous resurrection
father help us to accept this by faith
we thank you thank god for all you've
done for us
father i'm delighted for those who've
made decisions tonight to be baptized at
some point
give them the courage they need their
god to resist any attempt from anyone to
dissuade them whether from friends
family or for
now fathers believe let us leave
reflecting on what we have heard
let us leave with the assurance they got
that we are living in the second adam
the adam of life
watch over us tonight father
bring us back tomorrow to this place to
hear your word again
i offer this prayer from my heart in the
name of the second adam jesus christ let
all god's people say amen
you